to Johnny look of course you need to
deal with debts and does if you don't
you simply make Johnny's generation and
and our kids and our grandkids pick up
the sort of pick up the bill for this
generations mistakes it's how do you do
it you basically got the following
option you either borrow too much money
which is Labour's plan or you cut too
much which is the Conservatives plan and
when you cut of course you do need to
make savings and no one should deny that
but it's very important why you do it
and the difference between David Cameron
and myself is I believe you need to make
the necessary cuts because you have to
George Osborne a David Cameron make much
further cuts than is needed because they
want to and that's a huge difference
that is just simply wrong what we've had
is a balanced plan that's put more money
into their don't you apart from it's
also put more burden on some of the
richest people through instance through
having a stamp duty on expensive
properties but what I'm hearing in this
debate is that whereas I want to save
one out of every hundred pounds the
government spends we don't you not put
up taxes what I'm hearing is more debt
and more taxes more debt and more taxes
a lot more debt than more taxes it some
more direct question and it's definitely
more done that's all right throw that in
your browser side under causing David